hi everyone my name is shweta jain i'm a
postdoc at the university of utah
this is joint work with balram bhairava
eden hussage timur of garden and sichad
recommended
this talk is about fpt algorithms for
counting mere peaks in c close graphs
and i'll explain what those terms are
and
the stock is to appear in itcs 2022.
so the inspiration the motivation for
this work is actually real world graphs
so in network analysis on such graphs
one of the most important task is
counting sub graphs sub graphs like
try triangles cycles cliques near
cliques where by near cliques we mean
cliques that are missing a small
subgraph
and
these
counts of such
subgraphs they are used in applications
like community detection in edge
prediction in spam detection and many
more
applications
many of these problems are actually np
hard and yet something interesting has
happened in the last few years
extremely simple backtracking algorithms
have proven to work very well on these
graphs in practice
and there have been a number of works
that have been along these lines trying
to come up with faster
click counting and caplex counting
algorithms
and to give you an idea of how fast
these are
they're able to count clicks and ear
clicks in graphs with millions of
vertices and edges in minutes
so this is a plot from
[Music]
one of the recent papers
um
so the plot on the left uh it shows
the four large graphs on the x-axis
and the y-axis shows time in seconds on
the log scale
the sizes of the four graphs are shown
in the table on the right and as we can
see they easily run into millions of
vertices and edges
so ignore the red lines for now
the lightest blue line
that corresponds to the time taken by
that algorithm to count all cliques
in that graph
and the darker versions of blue
correspond to the same algorithm
when it
counted the number of cliques per vertex
and per edge as well which are
harder problems than
counting just the number of clicks
so
as you can see uh for three out of four
graphs the algorithm ran in minutes
and for our code it took about a couple
of hours
um and this was on a commodity machine
and this was a sequential algorithm so
it did not even use parallelism
bottom line is that these algorithms
work really really well in practice and
so clearly the structure of the graph is
helping the
algorithms and it's not worst case
so from the point of view of beyond
worst case analysis this raises the
question
what structure is leading to this
behavior
so in order to explain this
a graph class called c close graph was
recently proposed
in 2018 by
jacob fox timber of garden situated
commodore fan way and nickel wine
and the idea behind this graph class was
to capture this notion of triadic
closure which is a property that real
world graphs show
which is that
a friend of a friend is likely to be a
friend
the formal definition is that a graph is
said to have c closure
if every pair of vertices that have c or
more common neighbors are themselves
connected
so if you have two vertices you and v
that have c or more common neighbors
there has to be an edge between those
two vertices
if a graph is c closed it is also c plus
one closed c plus two closed and so on
and so we pick the lowest value of c
now
to give some examples uh c equals 1
corresponds to
disjoint union of cliques
and then you can have c equals 2s equals
3 and so on
so in the same paper the authors showed
that
maximal click enumeration can be done in
fbt time
and following that there have been a
number of works that have tried to show
that several other np-hard problems are
actually fixed parameter tractable
on this graph class
one of the notable works is that of uh
koana
from 2020
computing dense inspired subgraphs of
weekly c close
graphs
and they
amongst many other subgraphs they also
count cake lee k plexus which
we also have counted and so this was
concurrent work part of this was
concurrent work at that time
and there have been several other
papers
what we do in this work is that we count
we show that
fft algorithms exist for enumerating
several kinds of near cliques
um
so the first near clique is d plus one
plexus
these are complement graphs of boundary
degree graphs so it's easier to think of
so the near clicks that we've addressed
in some sense they're dense sub graphs
and so it's
in some cases it's easier to think of
the sparse version of it in the
complement graph
so d plus 1 plexus are essentially
complement graphs of bounded degree
graphs
then we also look at complement graphs
of boundary degeneracy graphs
and we also look at complement graphs of
bounded tree with graphs
so our proofs they come in two different
flavors
the first one is
we show that there actually exist very
simple backtracking
algorithms
that one can show our fpt for the c
close graphs
and then we also show
proofs using the three-step approach of
boxetta
we'll look briefly at what this approach
is and both of these approaches have
their own advantages
so the first one
has the advantage that it is closer to
what we observe in reality and so in
some sense it
it
gives us a better theoretical
understanding of why these algorithms
are working well in practice and it
helps to bridge that gap
and whereas the three-step approach
for certain cases it can
give us fpt algorithms uh even in cases
where we may not know a backtracking
algorithm
for that problem
and sometimes it can even lead to
slightly tighter bounds
in the process of
proving this
using this three-step approach
to prove the fpt prove that fpd
algorithms exist for
these near cliques
we also showed that we also showed a
moon versatile bound
on the number of two plexes
in general graphs and this is a tight
bound
we also showed that enumerating certain
kinds of
um
sub graphs near clicks is actually not
fpga so not every kind of near clique
can be counted in fpt time on in sql
graphs
um
we also give a very simple backtracking
based
algorithm for counting clicks and we'll
actually look at what this algorithm is
the algorithm of
foxcital was not backtracking and so
in
in that sense this new backtracking
algorithm that we give
it provides um
new understanding of why we're able to
do click counting
so efficiently in practice
okay
so the three-step approach of occital
these are the three steps that it
involved
so the first step basically
involves give either using an existing
bound or giving a new bound
for the number of maximal cliques uh so
since we this was for counting clicks
but
for any um near click that we're
interested in we would first give a
bound for the number of such
of that near clique in general grass
then we the second step would involve
showing that
counting the number of maximal
near cliques of that kind
in c close graphs is actually equivalent
to counting
the number of those maximal
near cliques in
a polynomial number of smaller graphs
usually bounded by size c
so this is where we heavily use the c
close property and
basically to convert so this gives an
fpd algorithm and then to convert this
into an enumeration algorithm we use
um a polynomial delay
algorithm
okay so that was the three-step approach
of fox at all and
i'm going to describe the backtracking
algorithm here just to give you a taste
of the kinds of things that we can do in
this c-close setup
so i'm going to describe an algorithm
which is a generic
click counting algorithm a lot of the
recent works in click counting are
sort of specialized versions of this
algorithm
okay so before i show that algorithm it
would be useful to
get some intuition for how clicks behave
so cliques are recursive structures
what that means is that
a subset of a clique is also bleak
so that suggests that if you want to
count all cliques
in the graph
one could
take a small clique
look at its common neighbors from the
set of common neighbors we
pick a vertex um add it to the clique to
get a bigger play
look at the new set of common neighbors
and so on and so if we do this process
exhaustively we will have discovered
every click in the graph
and
once we discovered every click to check
for maximality we can basically check if
there's any other vertex you can add to
that click
to get a bigger click
so checking for maximality is not
difficult
um in the process that i described here
we would end up
finding every click multiple times
so in order to avoid that
there's a simple trick which is
we order the vertices of the graph
and orient the edges from lower vertices
to higher vertices
so in this way we convert it to a dag
and once we convert it to a dac one can
show that
um
say if we wanted to count the number of
cake leaks in g then that would be
equivalent to counting the number of k
minus one clicks in the out neighborhood
of each vertex so for every vertex we
would look at its out neighborhood
and now we are interested in counting
the number of cliques in these out
neighborhoods
so it's the same problem
that we started with
but just on smaller instances
so
what does the algorithm do it records
this
so for
every vertex in this in these out
neighborhoods
and the algorithm will spawn a branch
calculate the new out neighborhoods
and so in this case 6 and 8 is
in the common out neighborhood of both
one and five
and
so on and so at every recursive call
we basically have a sub graph in which
we are interested in counting
cliques and so this process continues
until there are no more subgraphs left
and so in the end what we have is what
is called as a
recursive enumeration forest
so this
this recurs
this recursive tree it has certain
properties
so every path from root to a node
represents a unique clique from the
original graph
and
these
blue nodes
at level 1 they correspond to cliques of
size 1 at level 2 these correspond to
peaks of size 2 and so on
and every blue vertex here is a
recursive call that the algorithm makes
and so the total number of recursive
calls is equal to the number of clicks
in the graph
now what happens in the case of c close
graphs
so recall that at every node in the tree
we have a subgraph
that we are interested in
enumerating the cliques in and whenever
the sub graph is a clique
we don't need to explore further so if
you're interested in
getting
maximal cliques
if the subgraph that we are looking at
is a clique we can simply add it
to the vertices on
the path
and get a bigger click and then we can
check for maximality
so basically whenever the subgraph is a
click we we do not need to continue the
recursion tree
we can treat it as a leaf node
so the first thing that
we observe is that
in the case of c close graphs
all leaves at all nodes that left at
depth uh c
have to be leaf node
and which means that they have to be
cliques
this is because if they are not leaks
then that means that there is some
missing edge
in
in that sub graph and
all the vertices on the path
to that sub graph
are
common neighbors of that missing edge
that pair of vertices that are not
connected
and so because
we are this graph is a c close graph and
that means that there cannot be more
than c
common neighbors which means that
if we are beyond depth c
there cannot exist any missing edge in
the subgraph
right
now suppose we um so
the leaf nodes are all freaks and let's
say
the internal nodes uh the non-leaf nodes
we call them internal nodes
uh these being internal nodes um that
means that they do not have a missing
edge sorry they they are not clicked so
they have
a missing edge
now
a missing edge has at most
c common neighbors
now one can show that
so take any missing edge from the
original graph
in how many internal nodes can this
missing edge appear
so one can show that
since there are c
neighbors at most c neighbors
one can form at most
two to the c unique
sets
of these c vertices
and the path
to the node containing
the edge that we are the missing edge
that we are looking at
that path
has to be one of these
two to the c
subsets
so what that means is that
this missing edge can appear in at most
2 to the c
internal nodes
and given that there are at most
n square
missing edges
this gives us that
the number of internal nodes must be at
most
n square times 2 to the c
since every internal node can have at
most n children
this gives us that the size of the tree
is at most
n cube 2 to this
2 to the c
and
if you are a little more careful with
the analysis we can show that the size
of the tree would actually be
n square
times 2 to the c
okay
so that was for cliques and this
algorithm that i described
is actually used as a subroutine in the
algorithms for some of the other
near cliques
that i talked about
so the first new york league is d plus
one plex
um so
a d plus one plex so s is a d plus one
plex if every vertex in s
is adjacent to all but at most d
vertices in s
so you can think of this as
s is the complement of a bounded degree
graph
with degree at most d
a one plex would be a clique
so
the triple bound for
counting
uh
d plus 1 plexus is 2 to the n times n
square
and
for a very long time nothing better than
this was known only
recently
um
a recent work showed that
this can actually be done in time
gamma
to the power n times n square
and gamma depends on the d
and the value of gamma d is
less than 2
for all positive d
and
what we show
is that
there exists
um so we show a moon moves the type
theorem
uh for the number of maximal twoplexes
in say in general graphs so and this
bound that we give is actually tied
so other than the moon moser theorem
which is the theorem for
the number of maximal cliques
this is the only known
tight bound for
um
this kind of structure
so the theorem
says so this is a simplified version of
the theorem um the
actual running time is a little more
complicated and the analysis as well
but
essentially it says that maximal d plus
1 plexus can be enumerated in time
n to the 2 d times
2 to the c
and
i'll describe the simpler version of the
proof here for the slightly tighter
version
please refer the paper
so
a maximal d plus one plex can be
of two types one of two types
either it has no missing edge in which
case it is a clip
and so this can be counted using the
algorithm that i described earlier
the second case is when it has a missing
edge
now in this case
suppose
u v is the missing edge
we know that because of the c closed
property
there can be at most c vertices that are
common neighbors
of u and v
and because of the
d plus 1 flex property
we know that there can be at most 2 d
minus 2 vertices
such that those vertices are not common
neighbors of both u and v
so the
d plus 1 plex
you can also think of it as
a sub graph is a d plus 1 plex if
every vertex in that sub graph
is connected to all
vertices all other vertices of that sub
graph
except at most d vertices
and so that means that
the number of vertices that u
is not connected to in this sub graph is
at most
d
and the number of vertices that v is not
connected to is at most d
which means that the set that i have
marked in the circle on the right can be
of size at most 2 d minus 2 because u
and v are themselves not connected to
each other
and so this basically gives a bound on
the size of any maximal d plus 1 plex
so we can essentially look at every
missing edge
and enumerate these two sets and that's
how we get the
running time
to get a slightly tighter bound we
we essentially use polynomial delay
algorithms
[Music]
the next
sub graph that we
show fbt algorithms for
are
the bounded code degeneracy graph so
basically a graph is degenerate if every
induced subgraph has at least one vertex
with degree at most d
so graph is code degenerate if its
complement is
degenerate
and so the theorem goes that
maximal code degenerate graphs can be
enumerated in
n to the 2 d plus 4
times 4 to the c time and
we showed that this
i mean for enumeration this is in fact
tight
so there are examples where
um
at least in the exponent of n
um
it cannot be any
lesser than 2d
and
similarly we also show results for
bounded go tree width
so
the complement graph has
tree width at most
and in this case also we show that there
is an algorithm that runs in time n to
the t plus 4 times 4 to the c
that outputs all maximal induced sub
graphs with co2 with
less than or equal to t and this is
again tight as far as enumeration is
concerned
okay
so in the end
we show that there exists simple
backtracking based fpt algorithms for
counting near cliques and creeks in c
close graphs
we give a tight bound for the number of
two plexes in general graphs
but the most important
message
from this work
as was put by one of our reviewers
is that there are natural backtracking
based algorithms in practice for finding
large cliques in practical graphs
and the new c closed analysis framework
for the first time explains why
and thus further study of this c closed
framework is one of the most promising
directions for theoreticians to
contribute to this practically important
algorithmic setting
thank you
you